welcome back the new rockstars I'm Sam
basher and today I'm bringing you yet
another one of my world-famous MCU
rewatch breakdowns this is a series
where I watch all the Pioneer Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies and catch
every little Easter Egg and hidden
reference that they've got so far we've
done Iron Man Incredible Hulk Iron Man 2
Thor and today I'm gonna bring you
Captain America the First Avenger ray
mini-review time this movie's actually
better on the rewatch my first on
theaters I wasn't this Ian's biggest fan
it has a few flaws of course but you
know I actually enjoyed and this
actually makes the cap trilogy one of my
favorite trilogies of all time yeah
enough about that let's discuss every
Easter Egg and hidden reference I was
able to find awhile do my rewatch of
course here she's born a warning for cap
one two three MCU comics let's kick it
off with comic book Easter eggs those
are my favorite let's start with my main
man Captain America aka Steve Rogers
whose first appearance was in his very
own comic Captain America comics number
one in March of 1941 the first issue
selling nearly 1 million copies back
then
cool boy eventually he became a part of
Marvel Comics then was brought back to
life in the Avengers they thought
amounts the same thing to happen in this
movie it was very fun but I'll talk
about that more soon I do want to point
out those hiatal Captain America First
Avenger it's not like totally true I
guess like in like the timeline he was
first in the MCU but actually when the
Avengers were formed in the comics the
original roster was wasp and whole Iron
Man and in Thor and then eventually they
found cap yeah you know the giant black
eyes you know the story next I just want
to point out shield once again I've
actually talked about shield at length
and many other videos but just so you
guys know in the comics they are a
covert group that tackles supernatural
threats they're led by Nick Fury you
know the drill and their main foe being
hydra hydra made their debut in strange
tales number 135 in 1965 originally led
by not the Red Skull but by Baron von
Strucker who we saw in Avengers age of
Ultron that was eventually retcon of
course and then Red Skull became a part
of hydration also just want to point out
the red school's car I don't remember it
from the comics but it is just so cool
that I wanted to point it out right here
at the top of the video it is such a
cool concept for a car it's a bummer
that Nazis built it but still it's it
looks cool when they built it on set
it's actually like 18 feet long and it's
based on three different types of cars
from that era the mercedes-benz 540 k
mercedes-benz W 31 type g4 and the
Bentley mark 5
oh you know what let's talk about Red
Skull for a second since we already
brought him up his first appearance was
in Captain America comics number seven
in 1941 always appearing with that
cosmic cube it's the one he's mainly
using throughout this entire movie it's
a little bit different in the comics
Cosmic Cube usually is like a reality
altering device grants wishes basically
but in the MC you guys know it's a Space
Jam I did a whole video on the Infinity
stones you can go check that out right
down below also in the comics he didn't
look like that it was normally just a
mask that he would wear to go rob banks
to undermine capitalism there's other
ways that you could probably do that but
still it's comics it makes sense the
story of him taking the Super Soldier
serum and it messing up his like anatomy
and his face and whatnot is actually
from the 90s Captain America movie which
has a lot of callbacks in this new film
more on that soon I just want to point
out here blood a little bit falls on the
Hydra symbol hinting to Red Skull being
part of Hydra very fun anyways moving on
here in this alley scene we see Steve
Rogers holding a trashcan lid just like
his iconic shield which is pretty fun
and fun defect originally cap was seen
in this first comic with a gun and a
shield those were his main weapons but
eventually he started throwing that baby
around and he's like oh my goodness this
is so much better than a gun I'm gonna
just use this now in the same scene we
meet Bucky or James Buchanan Barnes one
of my favorite characters his first
debut was in Captain America comics
number one in 41 and originally he was
just a young boy that assisted cap on
missions but that was later retconned
and then he now has this like violent
streak in his past he's a much darker
character now if that's what means him
into becoming the Winter Soldier then
moving forward to the stark Expo we see
one of the very first heroes Marvel
Comics has ever had the Human Torch in
not Johnny Storm this was their robot a
synthetic man if you will way back when
this Human Torch cap and Namor the
Submariner the Submariner how we like to
say that would team up to fight for the
Allies in World War two and actually
that meant that Namor was gonna have a
little bit of a cameo in this film but
eventually that was cut I'm bummed about
that I also just want to point out when
we see Howard Stark II showing off a
flying car which in the comics shield
agents normally use those types of
flying cars Nick Fury especially on the
big fan of them we eventually see one of
them on aged as a shield but I'm getting
ahead of myself we then meet dr. Erskine
played by Stanley Tucci who is the
doctor responsible for making Captain
America very cool his first appearance
was in Captain America comics number one
in 1941 he developed a super soldier
serum and the vitamin Amir
I love the term vitae raise scooting
forward again we meet arm and Zola
played by Toby Jones his first
appearance was much later than everybody
else actually in Captain America 208 in
1977 he helped the Red Skull and the
Nazis by making gadgets and whatnot and
he eventually downloads his brain into a
mechanical body and he looks ridiculous
but I do love that design we actually
didn't couple Easter eggs for his
robotic body right here early on in the
movie when his head is blown up on that
screen and again later but more on that
soon moving forward just a little bit
more we meet one of my favorite
characters in the MCU agent Carter
played by Hayley Atwell not originally
from the you know early Captain America
comic she was later added to his history
and tells him suspense number 77 in 1966
as an old love interest of CAP I wish
she would just move to the present I
love her so much she's so great we then
meet a minor character from the Captain
America comics Gilmore Hodge he's one of
the jerks on the base that's messing
with Steve he originally appeared in
Adventures of Captain America number one
in 1991 but then we meet Tommy Lee Jones
his character Chester Phillips who
appear in Captain River comics in 1941
and he actually was the original person
to pick Steve Rogers or the experiment
to turn him into Captain America also I
just want to point out really quickly
that the sergeant in charge of training
Steve is Sergeant definitely played by
Damon driver who trained cap in Captain
America Comics number one as well oh my
god
inscription forward to Steve turning
into Captain America the spot who ends
up killing dr. Erskine is Heinz Kruger
who originally in the comics was a
Gestapo agent who ended up killing
himself but not by cyanide capsule in
the tooth which was pretty scary he
actually just actually electrocutes
himself classic comics never get another
nod to Steve shield when he rips off
that taxi door and he uses it to block
the bullets because you see that star on
the door get it just like a shield and I
wanted to point out that when Steve
decides to start selling war bonds in
his kept America getup this is actually
what a lot of comics were used for back
in the day they were used to sell war
bonds actually the characters within the
comics the Howling Commandos and Steve
Rogers and everybody would be trying to
push them as much as possible and here's
a quick shout out to the classic cap
uniform wings cuffs on the pants and all
it's ridiculous I loved how they used it
also kind of feels like a flashback to
the 1940s like little series the movie
series for cap kind of same costume and
of course you get the iconic scene of
him punching Hitler in the face which is
the scene that you see on the front of
Captain America Comics number one which
you actually end up seeing in this movie
the actual thing oh wow moving forward
to when he's entertaining troops
in Italy you see captures doodle in a
little bit notebook which is actually a
fun nod to cap being an artist
I'd buy somebody's work he was good
little monkey was cute I just wanted to
point out I noticed during this scene if
you look at red schools cost him it
looks a lot like the classic Hydra
costume which has a not-so-subtle H
usually all the way down from top to
tail in this at least it's just kind of
like a [ __ ] a little line work but still
wanted to point it out then moving to
Steve breaking out his friends from the
Hydra base we mean dum-dum Dugan play by
neal mcdonough and right here in his
little tank you hear him say wahoo a
little weird when you hear in the movie
but this is actually the battle cry of
the Howling Commandos and speaking of
the Howling Commandos I just wanted to
point out a few that we did get in this
film
Gabriel Jones play by Derek Luke he's
actually along with dum-dum Dugan some
of the original Howlin commandoes from
the comics everybody else is just kind
of like an amalgamation of other groups
we get Jim Morita played by Kenneth Cho
who fun fact has a grandson eventually
in the future who ends up being a
principal at spider-man's high school
very fun we also get a fun not an age as
a shield when Anton triplet one of the
agents says that his grandfather was
Gabriel Jones yay I love tie-ins yes I
have James Fonzworth played by JJ field
who originally in the comics was Union
Jack a superhero and then finally Chuck
Danny a played by Bruno Russia we went
forward again to Steve trying out all
those different types of shield we get
the first nod to vibranium you know that
awesome substance that doesn't absorb
vibrations doesn't make a lot of sense
you shouldn't be able to bounce them I'm
not a scientist though actually in the
comics the shield was a mix of
adamantium and vibranium but you can't
bad a man to him because Fox on those
rights but maybe not anymore who know
then moving forward once again to the
tragic death of Bucky on the train
actually in the comics I wanted to point
out that he dies on a drone and this is
actually the same scene where cat falls
off with a drought he falls in the
Arctic Ocean and he freezes and that's
when he's found in the future that's how
it usually plays out and then Bucky
explodes and we think he does but
actually he explodes falls in the water
as well kind of phrases and then is
recovered by Soviet scientists who
turned him into the Winter Soldier but
that's all the comic book Easter eggs I
was able to find let's talk about MCU
Easter eggs like the classic Marvel
intro in the beginning of this movie oh
I'm a big fan all solo nod to the kernel
meaning kernel Nick Fury of shield very
fun we also get a fun nod to tones big
Norway where the cosmic
was being hidden this is also the town
we saw in the flashback at the beginning
of the Thor film that gets frozen over
by the frost giants they made it out
okay it's alright we also get a nod to
Odin himself naming the tesseract as the
jewel of Odin's treasure room which is a
fun little nod to the Avengers because
at the end of that film the tesseract it
ends up going back to Asgard and it's
kept in the treasure room yay we also
get a nod to Udrih cell it's that giant
wooded mural you see that it's housing
the Cosmic Cube this is the tree that
connects all nine realms in Norse
mythology which I'm always a fan of
getting in a nod to also just want to
point out the stark Expo that made its
first appearance in Iron Man 2 you get
to see its granddaddy back in the 40s
posted by Iron Man's daddy also pay
attention very closely to the tech that
he has inside of the flying car
reversion technology sounds a lot like
repulsor techno I thought so some people
on the internet thought so moving
forward we go to the camp where Kappas
trained which we actually see again in
Captain America Winter Soldier but can't
wait to break down that move we don't
wanna get ahead of myself and now I want
to point out a few things from Steve's
transformation scene we know from The
Incredible Hulk that that team of
scientists was trying to recreate the
Super Soldier Serum that made Captain
America and we get a shot that's
recreated in both movies notice that
after he gets the serum his eyes shoot
open it seems very similar to when Bruce
Banner gets his serum in his eyes burst
open and you see that little green in
there me and the Hulk I'm inside but in
this he still got his baby blues they
moving forward to and Hyde returns on
their nazi generals listen to the sound
effect when that weapon fires like the
repulsor tech then this kind of plays
into a fan theory that people have that
the repulsor tech and the arc reactor
are actually Howard Starks design of
trying to recreate the energy that's
inside the tesseract maybe think about
it let me know what you think in the
comments down below and then really
quickly meet this one random fan asking
for an autograph from Steve this actress
is Laura haddock who actually plays a
bigger role down the line in the MCU as
star-lords mom it's okay she got cast
for two different things it's fine then
moving forward we see Armand Zola
choosing to work with shield which is a
fun nod to what happens in Winter
Soldier
then coming to the end of this movie we
see when the Red Skull gets shot up into
space most likely died maybe he didn't
who knows this looks to be the same
exact World Tree that we saw at the end
of Thor during the credits scene this
seems to be the World Tree that's gonna
clean all nine realms you know then
coming to be in the movie we see Nick
Fury of
courts play by samuel l.jackson it's
good to see you I miss you and as for a
post-credits scene their kind is one
it's actually just a full trailer for
Avengers the very first one and it's a
very mm trailer if you know what I mean
you should go look for it but throw that
all away really quick I just want to
point out some fun pop culture or
historical references that I was able to
catch while watching this movie when
Hydra finds the Cosmic Cube in Norway
you hear the Red Skull say this if
you're digging for trinkets in the
desert this has been confirmed to be a
fun little nod to Raiders of the Lost
Ark I'm a big fan of that then moving
forward to when the spy is trying to
escape in that aquatic vessel it looks
very weird I've never seen anything like
it
fun fact the creative team behind this
movie took a lot of concept vehicles
that the Nazis had and then brought them
to life in this movie and this one being
the Fisher dorch also just want to point
out that when they talk about the red
skulls obsession with the occult power
and myth is actually a well-known fact
that Hitler was kind of obsessed with
this on the side then moving forward to
when we see the reveal of the Red Skull
you see him take off in this like weird
helicopter plain-looking thing the name
for this would be the folk wolf tree
bull Mugen the name will be on the
screen you're very welcome
and this is one of my favorite little
Easter eggs I was able to find when
Tommy Lee Jones Hayley Atwell and Chris
Evans are all in that car they're
chasing after the Valkyrie Tommy Lee
Jones is driving and ends up hitting a
button that ends up boosting the car all
the way down the track this seems to be
a very fun Easter Egg to men in black
when he always tells Will Smith's
character to never hit that button and
then during the credits of this movie
all of the art is in the style of war
propaganda from America from that time
period you can see Rosie the Riveter how
fun and of course guys don't worry I
didn't miss it we get one Stan Lee cameo
thank the goodness when Steve is being
awarded one of his medal as you see Stan
Lee sitting in the audience as a general
saying I thought he'd be taller and
another little nugget just for you the
original actor that played Captain
America in the 90s movie is sitting
right next to him red Brown ladies and
gentlemen
whoo we made it thank you guys so much
for watching this let me know what your
favorite Easter Egg was or if I missed
anything in the comments down below make
sure you follow me on Twitter so we can
have fun discussions it's at only stupid
answers and got the valve from stupid
nailed it then make sure you like this
video share it and subscribe the new
rock stars for more breakdown so we've
got a lot coming your way make sure you
don't miss any of this series I'm a big
fan of it
again I'm Sam basher and I'll see you
next time